Attention! Cette vidéo s'adresse vraiment aux abonnés de la chaîne
à ceux  qui suivent la chaîne, qui aiment ça et pas
qui regardent une vidéo de temps en temps
ca risque de ne pas vous intéresser je vous le dis tout de suite
pour pas que vous soyez déçu c'est vraiment une vidéo
qui est en relation avec la chaîne et l'avenir de la chaîne
Mort de rire production présente: Bwaaaaaaaa!
Salut! nous sommes samedi soir!
Quoi? Mais non c'est pas vrai on est dimanche!
Oui mais je fais cette vidéo samedi soir parce que
ce soir je joue sur la péniche le nez rouge
en spectacle et je vais vous voir puisque depuis le mois d'octobre c'est complet
donc j'imagine que vous êtes nombreux!
et j'ai peur de ne pas avoir le temps de faire la vidéo
et de la monter pour la mettre à l'heure pour aujourd'hui
Un diablozor! Ca film?
Ca fait bien longtemps qu'on t'avais pas vu dans
une vidéo toi! .-Exactement! Ca y'est je suis cuit.-
[Fabien chante] Il est beau ton bateau!
p'tin je crois que c'est la première fois que je chante un peu juste en impro
Qu'es-ce que tu fais Diablo? tu caches les complices ou pas?
.- je remets le rideau! je remets le rideau!-. [Fabien] d'accord!
.-je remets le rideau.. [Fabien] évite de dire qu'il y a des complices devant la caméra par contre
D'accord mon vieux COMplice
mon vieux.. oh putain!
Si toi aussi tu as compris cette vanne fait un #jesuischoqué dans les commentaires
Là je vous fais voir ce qu'on appelle la conduite du spectacle
donc on va commencer pas un numéro ou je mets quelqu'un
au sol et je lui écrase le sternum
Ensuite je le mets sous hypnose
et je mets des choses comme ça dans sa bouche
si c'est une fille plutôt mignonne
bon, je deviens un petit plus entreprenant quoi
la suite du numéro c'est
de regarder si le public reste quand même dans la salle ou pas
et si il y a des témoins ou pas
si des gens sont partis pour qu'il n'y ait plus du tout de témoins
après je brise la nuque!
un classique!
Il me reste que 13 vidéos à faire pour terminer
le défi que je m'étais lancer cette année: faire une vidéo pas jour!
Depuis le 1er janvier au 31 décembre
Les 366 vidéos je les ai presque atteintes
ça fait bizarre en fait d'arriver à ce stade là
et je travaille depuis un petit moment
sur comment ça va se passer  l'année prochaine
qu'est-ce que je vais faire je vous annoncerai tout ça début
janvier mais c'est là ou j'ai besoin de vous
j'aimerais dans les commentaires de cette vidéo
que  vous me disiez ce que vous aimeriez en terme de
de périodicité
une tous les jours.. une par heure...
vous décidez tout est possible
vraiment le rythme idéal que vous aimeriez?
est-ce qu'il y a des séries particulières que vous aimeriez?
des sujets? des formes différentes?
puisque je pense  sans trop vous en dévoiler
que je vais garder des vidéo qui ressemblent un peu au mental vlog
mais je vais m'ouvrir aussi à d'autres styles de vidéo
et à d'autres série. Peut-être que vous aussi vous avez des idées
genre  me donner un défi à réaliser et je le réalise
Puisqu'on ne sera plus sur le rythme de "une" par jour
c'est plus envisageable.. Parce qu'au final
je ne vais pas passer moins de temps sur la vidéo, ça va me prendre au tant de temps qu'avant
mais j'aurai plus le temps de préparer des choses
de les faire et de faire des plus gros montages
vous pouvez me dire les thèmes  que vous aimeriez que j'aborde
vous pourrez me dire la périodicité "ok"
le style de série, le style de vidéo
je vous avais déjà posé une question pour savoir si
j'ouvrais une chaîne secondaire ou pas pour
faire les vlogs que j'avais envie de faire
la plus part des réponses ont été "non"
donc j'en ouvrirais pas! c'est bien pour ça que je vous pose les questions
et il y a une majorité de personnes
et ça c'est plutôt drôle, qui disait
moi j'aime pas les vlogs je déteste ça
n'ouvre pas de chaîne secondaire! Et je trouvais ça marrant parce que
c'est des gens qui n'aiment  le vlogs mais qui préfèrent quand même
que je les laisse sur la chaîne, ce que je peut comprendre en soit
mais c'était drôle de se dire "non j'aime pas mais mets le quand même sur cette chaîne là et pas sur une autre!"
donc pour ce qui est vlog j'ai déjà
une idée de comment ça va se passer
il y en aura très peu, il y en aura une dizaine dans l'année
mais d'une manière un peu particulière
bref vous avez compris l'idée c'est une
vidéo mental vlog
vraiment  spéciale pour le coup
puisque je vous pose simplement la question qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
vous, voir l'année prochaine
qu'es ce qui vous ferait triper?
qu'es qui fait que vous
trouveriez encore un intérêt  à regarder cette chaîne
Moi  je vais continuer à travailler dessus et
je pense le 2 janvier je vous ferais
une vidéo pour vous dire, comment va se passer l'année
quelles sont les défis que je vais essayer de relever
quelle va être la forme, la périodicité.. etc..
alors je sais que j'aurais pu faire un sondage directement sur
youtube ou un google form' mais je vois bien
que quand je fais ça il y a moins de personnes qui participent
donc mettez tout dans les commentaires
je vais référencer tout ça et je
m'embêterai moi à remettre tout dans un tableau XL
afin de voir un peu se qui s'en dégage
mais ne vous dites pas que votre avis importe peu
il importe vraiment! Donc
peu importe que ça déjà été dit 1000fois
ou pas du tout dans les commentaires
ou que vous pensiez que se soit une idée ridicule
mettez moi tout ce qui vous concerne vous!
c'est important pour moi de continuer à lire les commentaires
et là c'est important pour moi d'avoir vos
avis individuellement vraiment un par un
et pas un truc de masse ou un sondage de masse
je  crois que j'ai tout dit
au moment ou vous regarderez cette vidéo je serai déjà
euh.. levé
oui je suis triste que le défi s'arrête, mais regarde
je suis content de récupérer un peu plus de sommeil
Hâte de lire vos réponses! si le concept de vous demandez votre
avis vous plaît pensez à liker et à vous abonner
et rendez-vous demain à 17h CIAO!
ah oui! Pour ceux qui sont encore là euh
j'ai commencé à recevoir les lettres pour le jeu
des 200 k, il y en a déjà 5000 de reçues
j'ai pas encore tout ouvert j'ai pas encore
tout trié parce que j'essaie de trouver mon vrai courrier à l'intérieur
parce que tout arrive à la boîte postale ou vous avez envoyé donc je suis en train de faire le tri
je commence les envois qu'à la fin du mois
donc vous inquiétez pas
Re-CIAO!